[Music]
the National Health Service has come a
long way in 70 years the NHS has
improved the nursing care so much
generations of Britons have cherished
its care forgiving its floors and still
considerate the pinnacle of public
service but like the country it serves
the NHS is changing this is your blood
pressure now is a little bit high it's
eight decade brings huge challenges and
hard choices half of our workforce is
either on the cusp of retirement or
above retirement age and to sustain it
we may have to change - it's my fault
upon the weight so I'd rather not have
to burn in the NHS with it the NHS is
our best loved institution defining the
national character like the weather or
the landscape but as it turns 70
is it fit for the future
[Music]
the Kendall Ramblers Club booting up for
another assault on the Yorkshire Dales a
contemporaries of the National Health
Service the first generation to enjoy
free health care the NHS delivered their
children and in later life its tended to
their ills having prostate cancer in a
heart attack so yeah it's pretty
important that you do whatever you can
to keep things going it's very clearly
in great difficulties now last week I
tried to get a just a telephone
appointment with my GP and it was going
to be almost two weeks before I could
actually speak to a GP here we are
thinking great we're doing this walking
because it's keeping his fit we're gonna
live for longer but it's the care right
there who's looking after us after us
and how are we going to afford it I was
convalescing after prostate cancer and
the preliminaries and the operation and
the post operation service was excellent
and it's enabled me to have an active
life since two and a half years ago my
wife died and for the fortnight that she
was seriously ill there was I would say
loving care of someone who is beyond
recovery so I'm a great supporter
these retirees are not slowing down but
their generation living a dozen years
longer on average than when the NHS was
founded and with more complex illnesses
is threatening to overwhelm the service
this leaflet it's one of many challenges
unforeseen when from the wreckage of war
the NHS was founded as the jewel of
Britain's new welfare state it tells you
what the new National Health Service is
so in 1948 I had been in casualty for
for one year when the National Health
Service took over the thing I noticed
most was we began to get more doctors
we'd only had one casualty officer and
the poor man he worked 24 hours a day
when the nh-2 took over people could
start to come into hospital for anything
so of course our workload increased
immensely
that wasn't my staff there Janet Harding
Ham was 27 and a nurse at Norfolk and
Norwich Hospital she spent the next 30
years in the NHS as it transformed
healthcare the NHS has improved the
nursing care so much because of the
operations now people are no longer in
bed for any length of time they're up
and out aren't they
whereas our patients were in four weeks
and in bed often they had to be nursed
in the bed and the operations that are
taking place down like hot operators but
really just beginning while I was
working there nearly 40 years after
janet retired the fundamentals of
nursing have not changed but the NHS
today faces huge challenges is a little
bit high rosario was recruited to
Queen's Hospital in Romford directly
from Italy because of a chronic shortage
of homegrown nurses
had already most of our patients are
elderly and have a multitude of ills
like Ernest who's 84 and relies on
social care to remain at home the aging
population is a huge new burden there
are as many patients in hospital with
dementia today as there were with
tuberculosis when the NHS was founded so
he has had abdominal pain and vomiting
for the past four days the daily demand
of accidents and illness also has to be
met Richard is feeling sick not of the
service has come to his aid fantastic
you just might feel proud of the English
I'm gonna give you anyway you will being
in this country he tell you that often
yeah when you do a little badge
gratitude is one of the few commodities
not in short supply the staff and beds
are placing those on the front line
under huge pressure the complexity in
the workload of our patients you know is
immense and the needs and the
requirements is high however you know we
have fundamental really good teams and
people in place they really support and
help that you know we need to be mindful
that there is a increase in demand and
there's an increase in terms of you know
the acuity how unwell our patients are
that that comes for us and we need to
adjust and adapt to meet their needs as
best as possible technology has been
transformed in 70 years - but medical
advances have increased costs
okay David you're all set we're going to
leave the room man this radiotherapy
machine is the first of its kind in
Britain offering concentrated treatment
in a fraction of the time of older
technology but with a multi-million
pound bill it's a price worth paying
says David who has prostate cancer it's
not cheap and these new machines are
going to be wonderful for the cancer
treatment so obvious talk about the
prospect of them more money coming in to
the edge there's nothing that'll be a
great thing if they can despite
investments like this cancer is one area
where NHS outcomes are worse than the
European average and British patients
are more likely to die from stroke and
heart attack than in comparable
countries yet the public hold the system
responsible support for nurses and
doctors is unwavering the home nations
have devolved control over health
responsibility for reviving the NHS in
England Falls to Simon Stevens he's got
a five-year funding deal worth up to 20
billion pounds now he's working on a
ten-year plan that will set out what the
NHS will and will not do for the money
the range of services that the Health
Service offers is going to continue to
expand the way in which we interact with
the health service will continue to
change but fundamentally the deal is
that we as the citizens and taxpayers of
this country fund a service that will be
available for us when we need it and
that's going to endure there have been
big reductions in waiting on the NHS
over the last ten years or so we want to
keep short waits for I&E care and for
planned surgery but we also want to make
big improvements in cancer care and
unaddressed areas such as young people's
mental health services for most of us
the NHS means a GP the family doctors in
every town who've been both first port
of call for everyday problems and
gatekeepers for 70 years in Darwin in
Lancashire has across the country they
are under pressure
I think at least half of our workforce
is either on the cusp of retirement or
above retirement age and continuing to
work so yes what practices in the area
have had problems recruiting and it will
it will get worse one solution trial
across the NHS has been to train the
staff they do have to take on extra
responsibilities Maria was a
receptionist now she's an assistant
practitioner the job entitles me to look
after patients with more complex needs
so kind of the diabetic patients and
patients with chronic disease such as
diabetes epilepsy hypertension chronic
heart disease learning disabilities kind
of the list is endless really the work
being done down there in Darwin is part
of the NHS is wider plan to deal with
the challenges of today in the jargon
it's called integration in plain terms
it means getting services across a
region to work together
hospitals GPS crucially social care and
here that means from the Lancashire mill
towns to Cumbria way up there in the
north right across the Blackpool on the
west coast
a few miles away near Preston the NHS is
easing pressure on hospitals by taking
advanced treatment into people's homes
Rachel has been tetraplegic since a bus
crashed into her moped when she was 16
she has 32 years experience of the NHS a
few years ago I had tendon transfers
because there's a tetraplegic you lose
function in yep fingers and your hands
they take tendons out of your arm they
split it and take it to your thumb so
that as you can see I've got the grip
you needs intravenous antibiotics for an
infection and until recently that would
have meant six weeks on a ward it means
that my life can go on as normal I work
part time so it means that I can get the
IV done and still get to work and really
just my life isn't altered in any way
hospitals and not the place for me if I
can help it
changing the way the NHS and his staff
work is crucial but there is one group
that has more power than any to ensure
it is sustainable us this Weight
Watchers club they're not just helping
themselves there's some great techniques
in there for mindfulness mindful eating
it's not just us that are improving our
lives it's for our family as well that
ripple effect almost 2/3 of us are obese
or overweight with increased risks of
cancer and heart disease and diabetes is
an emerging epidemic the doctor told me
I was borderline diabetic and he wanted
to put me on all these tablets and I
said no I really don't want to go on
medication give me six month and I'll
see if I can do something myself
and I went back after six month and it
was much improved I've got asthma
my mom had a bad chest and I was willing
the same way very or getting chest
infections and one thing and another now
Smith asked me we're getting worse so
actually we're losing weight that's
helped a lot it's my fault put on the
weight so I'd rather not have to burn in
the NHS with it when you've got you know
loads of other pressures as long as the
NHS is free at the point of use
prevention will be the key to its long
term health but changing lifestyles will
not be enough without the funding and
staff to improve care
70 years since the NHS was founded we
still put our lives in its hands in its
future he's in ours
Paul Kelso sky news
you